blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman
republicans are now claiming both some
kind of vindication
and some kind of cover-up because
president joe biden has
ordered a closer intelligence review of
the origins
of the covid 19 virus and pandemic
and biden revealed that earlier this
year per cnbc
he asked the intelligence community to
assess did it emerge
from human contact with an infected
animal or did it emerge from a
laboratory
accident increasingly there are more and
more
people saying we need to study whether
this was
man-made and it's really important to
understand
that these are different ideas and that
they there is not a current belief that
covid was man-made and in fact
if it were based on the best medical
science i've read
it would have a different sort of
signature
that would be noticeable when you
examine the virus now let's let's really
understand what is going to be examined
here which i think is great and by the
way
those claiming that the left never
wanted to look at this
go talk to the people who said that i
have said from the very beginning
investigate everything we want truth i
want truth
um but uh regardless the idea persists
that
the left doesn't want to know the truth
uh i very much want to know the truth so
option one
contact spread to humans from an
animal to humans likely in wuhan and
spread from there
scenario number two this came from an
animal
and was being studied in a lab possibly
in wuhan
and due to an accident it leaked and
spread there to the worldwide human
population
and then you have scenario three the
most conspiratorial and the one for
which we have no
evidence which is this was some some
kind of a human-made bio weapon that was
deliberately released into the wild by
china now
that first piece doesn't really pass the
sniff test in part because
it has been so damaging not only to
china
but to other countries around china that
china has no reason to try to go after
so the u.s centric nationalist view is
china would have been motivated to do
this in order to attack the u.s most of
the deaths have been elsewhere
i think globally officially there are
about 3.5 3.6 million kova deaths
and in the u.s there's officially 600
thousand that means that
five-sixth of the deaths were elsewhere
and many in china
very would be a very very strange thing
to do now as a reminder
uh the biden administration has been
okay
uh investigating this for a long time
here is white house deputy press
secretary
karine jean-pierre two days ago saying
uh the biden administration has not
ruled anything out and is open to
exploring further
another question on uh kovid
the language that you all use
specifically mentioned an accident
does that mean that uh you've ruled out
or the ic has ruled out that it was
uh deliberate or not an accident we
haven't ruled out anything yet
um but again we're going to go through
this you know this re-doubling down of
another
of a 90-day review and we'll have more
to share but yet
the idea will not go away that joe biden
doesn't want to investigate this
remember this is from earlier this week
we looked at these clips
this is from monday here is peter ducey
from fox news
asking white house press secretary john
saki but why won't
joe biden look into it what will it take
for him to look into it
new investigation but with 589
920 dead americans at what point does
president biden say
we don't want to wait for the who we
don't know what they're doing this needs
to be an american-led
effort to get to the bottom of what
happened well first of all we need
access to the underlying data and
information in order to have that
investigation and why not but he talks
all the time about how he's known
president xi for a long time
so why can't he just and we need them
for that information i think you're
misunderstanding how this process
actually works
an international investigation led by
the world health organization
is something that we've actually been
pressing for for several months
in coordination with a range of partners
around the world
we need that data we need that
information from the chinese government
what we can't do
and what i would caution anyone doing is
leaping ahead of an actual international
process
we don't have enough data and
information to jump to a conclusion at
this point in time
so is there any amount of the
casualties from colbit in this country
that would make you want to
not wait for an international effort and
just do it
as well i i have to say i think the
family members of the
loved ones whose lives have been lost
and deserve
accurate information data not the
jumping to a conclusion without having
the information necessary to conclude
what the origins are
what we do share everyone in this
country as a desire to know
how this started where it started and
prevent it from ever happening again
that's something we all share go ahead
and then not satisfied i guess with that
answer
asking the same question on tuesday
uh and getting a very similar answer
does president pine think these theories
we hear more about now that kova 19 may
have been man-made and escaped from a
lab in china
are a wacky conspiracy theory or based
on what he has heard and been briefed on
does he think that's possible
well we went through this journey
together yesterday so let's do it again
uh so the president believes there needs
to be an independent investigation
one that's run by the international
community it's an international pandemic
that has killed hundreds of thousands of
people around the world
he believes the chinese need to do more
to put forward data to be more
transparent and in the second phase of
this
effort he's certainly hopeful that will
be the case and he believes that every
theory should be explored through that
process but that we shouldn't jump to
conclusions before
that data and that information is made
available thank you and on the rise
so listen there's really no reason not
to
do this uh whether or not it was
engineered as some conspiracists claim
although we have no evidence for that at
this point in time why wouldn't we want
to find out more about the origins of an
infectious disease
that became a global pandemic completely
overtook us
uh and created the chaos that it did
over the last 16 17 months
so um again the best science i've read
is that had it been engineered by
humans it could not have been done with
any of the
known tools of genetic manipulation okay
when you use the known tools from
genetic manipulation
they leave evidence in the genome that's
not there
so again applying some sort of occam's
razor here
if this was engineered it was engineered
in a way that it was done with
heretofore
unknown methods such that that
engineering
is unable to be detected that's a big
leap
and we don't have any evidence of that
investigate it
investigated wuhan was researching bat
born coronaviruses and classifying them
and looking at mutation rates and
behaviors
so is it possible a tech got scratched
while they were working with these
samples it's plausible certainly
and it should be investigated the wet
market hypothesis from the beginning
quite plausible let's let's investigate
it uh but the
idea the fake scandal now that the right
is trying to create
that the left is unwilling to explore it
or that the left is covering it up or
that this is somehow dr
fauci's fault he was involved in the
creation
to then make money from the uh solution
you know there is no evidence for any of
those things and
absent that evidence we should just be
saying investigate do an investigation
now
i saw a couple kind of weird comments
from some claiming to be on the left
saying the lab leak hypothesis is racist
because it implies that chinese
scientists are just incompetent come on
guys
we're getting nowhere with that trash
okay
um accidents can happen anywhere for all
we know
it's not even all chinese scientists
that were working in that lab
it's that we're going down a really dumb
path to say even exploring this is
racist even raising the question is
racist
that's nuts assuming that it was any of
these things though
until we actually have some evidence
that's also not going to make any sense
to me
send me your thoughts i'm on twitter at
dpakman this is it guys
monday memorial day it's time for the
one day membership special
okay we will do a one day huge
membership discount on the last day of
may and
on federal holiday memorial day if you
want to get on the list to be notified
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show is
primarily funded
by the david pakman show membership
program popular
in uh over 80 countries i believe um
sign up yourself today at joinpakman.com
use the coupon code better21 to save
hugely you can just save absolutely
hugely off of a membership
okay let's hear from some people in the
audience we do now take calls via
discord you can go to davidpakman.com
discord if you would like to talk to me
let's
start how about with kelsey
from colorado kelsey you are on the air
kelsey you're on the air please unmute
yourself and then we will be able to
chat
all right and last opportunity for
kelsey
from colorado no
kelsey from colorado that's really
sad it's not it doesn't bode
particularly well
when we start off like that
uh all right why don't we try nick from
new york next
nick you're on the air uh hi david
hello going i'm doing well thank you
um i was just wondering i've been trying
to ask you this question
what is the best way to pass voting
rights
legislation without uh the supreme court
striking it down
why would the supreme court strike it
down like
hr1 you know conservatives like to argue
that it's
unconstitutional right but conservatives
often argue that things
are unconstitutional and they're just
wrong
yeah what do they say is
unconstitutional about hr1
they say that well they they force
states to
um you know change their
redistricting rules and you know
make them have all these sorts of things
having to do with voting my position on
this is make them prove it's
unconstitutional make them actually do
it because
just republicans saying it's
unconstitutional to me it's
it's it's just not good enough and if
they actually want to fight that make
them do the work
uh i don't think it's a reason not to
push for hr one and i
i hope it passes and put put republicans
in the position of having to actually
uh sue and appeal and appeal and appeal
i wouldn't be scared away by that
but what makes you know the federal
government
mandating that states change their
election laws constitutionally
well the the the problem is the framing
so
republicans frame it as h.r 1
would be the federal government telling
states how to run
elections there's a completely different
way to understand it which is
the federal government uh much like with
the voting rights act which was
completely constitutional
can set basic parameters and
guidelines that must be met by states
for their constitutions to be considered
fair and valid
and that held with the voting rights act
and
there's no reason to believe in
particular that it wouldn't hold with
hr1 i mean
maybe aspects of hr1 would be found
unconstitutional but the argument you're
repeating is not a very strong one
yeah i'm i'm simply just trying to
you know debunk these these um
he's talking of course of course yeah no
i i
just make them prove it make them prove
it is the point
okay um and i would like to ask you
another thing
okay um what is um
i i am wondering why don't you mention
how joe manchin and kirsten cinema are
bought out by corporations i don't see
you talk about that
we do i mean i know less about cinema
but
joe manchin and west virginia business
interests are something we have talked
about before
um i think maybe if you're not hearing
me talk about it as much recently
it it's sort of i mean it's not as much
a part
of the big picture if you have something
where there are even more democrats that
aren't on board
or you need 60 so it's not even about
just democrats but
at least as far as joe manchin goes we
have talked about that
all right um yeah all right my friend
thank you very much for the call i
appreciate it
let's speak next to uh how about alex
from fairfax
virginia hi there can you hear me david
yes i can
hi david well i'm a relatively new
listener
uh and i really like your content i
agree with a lot
with a lot what you're saying but i'm
also a very uh socially conservative
person okay and this is something that
uh
is something that you talked about but i
was wondering what your take
on uh abortion is i i know that you were
generally pro-choice and i was wondering
if i could just
um take like 30 seconds to tell you what
i believe about that
and see what get your thoughts on that
is that all right sure yeah
so uh to me i think you know
once someone wants an egg is fertilized
in the womb that's when your unique dna
comes out
comes out of where unique and so
uh hold on a second wait a second wait
wait wait
when you said that when an egg is
fertilized your unique dna
comes out what do you mean by that so
the everyone has their own unique dna
and uh and no one's to unless you're
identical twins everyone's dna is unique
and they think that
and that's the thing that makes you you
you know your your body everything about
you
okay and uh that originates at the time
of conception is what i'm trying to
say sorry if i wasn't clear so that was
what i was trying to say that's okay
that originates and so from that point
on
you know the only thing different from
like
uh the a fertilized egg
to nine months in the womb or baby is
just time
really and so i feel like at that point
from conception
um that's when a human life really
begins though and that
they should have rights at that point
though what do you think about that
let's explore that so by analogy um
it sounds like you're saying that if i
plant a cucumber seed
today and it germinates meaning at that
point
it has germinated as it has gone beyond
being just a seed it is no longer just a
sperm cell right you and you you know
the analogy i'm using here
uh i i think i'm following okay
the day of germination of my cucumber
seed
the only difference between that and
five months later when i have a full
plant with a dozen cucumbers that i can
eat on it the only difference is time
would you agree with that
i mean so long we don't mess with like
normal processes that happen
i mean we have to make sure the ground
is watered
make sure is i mean i get where their
analogy is going i wouldn't say right
so i guess the i guess my question is
yeah but i would generally agree
i would generally agree with maybe a
little caveat but sure so
would so by your by your uh statement
about the day of the the the
uh you know the first day of conception
and nine months later the only
difference is time
a one day germinated cucumber seed is no
different than a plant with 12 cucumbers
that you could eat and so
would you treat both of those with the
same care and in the exact same way
i wouldn't say that they are exactly the
same but when it comes in the specific
context of like
uh a baby in the womb though uh
unlike a uh a cucumber i do believe
when it comes to human life i think
we're talking about like rights
when you're saying about treating them
the same way i believe that the
there are rights that need to be
recognized right now but i'm not saying
i'm not saying treating cucumbers and
humans the same way what i'm saying is
is your understand would you relate to
a one-day germinated cucumber seed the
same way you would relate to
a cucumber plant with 12 edible
cucumbers on it
not a cucumber no no so then why would
it be the exact same thing with humans
uh because generally we relate to humans
differently we do than we do with
cucumbers
okay but i think the point becomes at
what point
do we say that legally
we should be dealing with them in the
same way and the science
no science that i've seen i mean
philosophically and conceptually what
you're saying about the day of
conception might
resonate with you but scientifically
i've seen nothing that says that what's
there on the day of conception
is anything like what's there at nine
months never mind
after the second trimester never mind
after the first
trimester so i guess the question would
be
you might feel as though these are
equivalent things but there's no science
i've seen that says that they
are and is there like uh
just to make sure i'm not quite sure
what you're saying so is there
can you give an example of what type of
evidence would you need
to convince you on a science basis that
there would be similar things or
different doctors have different views
some are talking about
at a certain point of neurological
development
others talk about when would when would
the fetus be viable
outside of the womb i mean i think we
have to go to science and medical
science with that question i don't know
that you and i will sort of sort that
out
yeah sure so i understand your so just
to make sure i understand what you're
saying
from your perspective just because the
jury's still out on the scientific point
of view the experts
are still arguing about it you don't
feel the need to
take a stand it's not that the experts
are arguing about it
it's that there's no medical perspective
i've read
that says the day of conception
you have something that we would
logically assign rights or
personhood to the debate seems to be
much narrower at a much later period of
the pregnancy
sort of like where most americans
believe
abortion should be legal in most cases
the debate around conception for me
is a false debate it's an arbitrarily
extreme debate
because very few people even think that
that's a debate worth having the debate
really is about
late-term abortion and and you know only
the most extreme
religious conservatives or social
conservatives are talking about
conception so i don't even engage in the
debate really
because it's just it's not where the
science is and it's not where society is
okay david well uh if that if that's
your perspective i understand uh i
appreciate your content
thank you for everything oh one last
thing i just want to clear up on
um you said that the science hasn't gone
to a point
where uh we don't know if we should
assign rights to them
or not i didn't say that what i said is
there is no
case i've seen made that is a
science or or medical case
that justifies personhood and rights
for um cells a day after conception
okay thank you for clearing that up
david i appreciate your perspective i
appreciate what you do and it was a
pleasure talking to you
the pleasure is all mine i thank you
very much uh very very good okay
it's i mean it's a little surprising
people still want to debate at
conception i didn't even think anybody
was debating that anymore
but but people are people are
let's go next to uh why don't we go to
william from minnesota william you're on
the air
hello david can you hear me yes i can hi
i'm just hoping to pick your brain a
little bit
about uh-oh i have to admit whenever i'm
at a dinner party and someone says they
want to pick my brain
i try to head for the hills that's a big
red flag that things are going to go bad
is that a saying it's a bat yeah that's
a that's that's a dinner party red flag
let's
see if we can recover from it though i
was hoping to hear your perspective
on an untapped reservoir beautiful way
of
uh funds building and reaching out to
new audiences
when it comes to politics um
specifically when it comes to different
streaming platforms such as
twitch and youtube okay it seems like
both political parties just seem to have
this aversion
to branching out into the new generation
of media
specifically when i talk about this and
thinking about the different
fundraising that can come from
these different platforms such as say
for twitch
uh pastilli an australian um
gamer the primarily stream
escape from tarkov raised 1.2 million
australian dollars
for a children's fundraiser for
children with cancer okay uh let's see
if i can give another another example
uh example dr lupo well i know
what was your what was your question
people people do fundraisers and they
raise money through their platforms give
it given that what was your question
given that why does it seem like with
these numbers
that the political parties and
these different political actors seem to
not respect
that as a way to move forward
politically politically
you're saying political actors don't
respect
fundraising as a way or twitch
fundraising as a way to move forward
but i wanted to expand on my point um
but having been cut off
it seems like these people can reach
such massive audiences
and these fundraisers can
gain huge amounts of cash it seems like
there's just not the will to move
forward to use
both twitch and youtube streaming and
the audiences that come along with them
to build a political
political career and i don't understand
why
to build a so you're saying uh someone
who wants to be a candidate
who does fundraising on youtube and
twitch
rather than uh doing the things
candidates might normally do
or even alongside them not necessarily
in spite of what other candidates may
normally do oh
i think i see candidates do that i mean
i've seen you know particularly
in the era of the pandemic zoom
fundraisers and live stream fundraisers
i think i do see it maybe it's just not
being done as much or it's not as
sophisticated yet i also recall
uh congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez uh doing a
live streaming playing games and doing
major fundraisers for causes that she
cares about so i think it is being done
to some degree
okay um and just as a
follow-up question i was wondering your
thoughts on the validity
of this when it comes to moving forward
in the political
climate that we see i think it's
completely valid and i think it's
absolutely fine assuming it doesn't
break any campaign finance law okay
i think that that's a perfectly nice
uh perspective thank you very much all
right thanks william there is william
from minnesota we're going to take a
quick break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we're going right back to the phones
momentarily
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 better 21.
we are taking phone calls sort of
they're really kind of like
voip calls i guess through the david
pakman show discord which you can find
at davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go to
i believe it's nikki from germany
nikki from germany is that right
nikki from germany you're on the air
nikki from germany last chance
and nikki from germany is gone let's go
to bryce
from illinois bryce you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes i can
fantastic how are you doing today
i'm doing well good
so i've just got uh i guess a
couple quick questions kind of joking
mildly just to
i don't know get the break the ice a
little bit and then i guess more of a
serious question if that's all right
that works with you
okay so first question
boxers or briefs oh i i
i have a video on youtube about this so
i refuse to answer it in perpetuity
you just have to go and look at the
boxers or briefs video on youtube
oh i i see fair enough fair enough
um i guess my other question is you live
in new york city right
near new york city yeah i don't say
exactly where
okay fair enough but i guess what's your
uh transport situation
like between i guess your home and
office i have not been
on uh i have not been on public
transport since
february of 2020.
i just what do you do in order to get
around you have a car
i have a car i have a car
i've been getting really into small
unique electric
vehicles lately they have electric
unicycles whole
host of interesting things so just a
matter of curiosity more than anything
but yeah no these are serious questions
so i
i guess i'll propose a more serious
question um
have you seen the film idiocracy uh by
mike judge
yes i have
what do you think the odds are with you
know the 50
of the republican party that refuses to
acknowledge that
joe biden won the election do you think
that that 50
could potentially weigh us down enough
to where that is
a reasonably uh valid situation that
could
happen if we don't blow ourselves up
beforehand
yeah i don't know specifically what
which part you mean but yes
i've expressed significant concern about
the fact that uwa
disagreements about what the tax rate
should be
or how big a um
you know being just the abhorrent
uh complete lack of trust in in science
yes yes that's extremely concerning that
is extremely concerning
i don't know how we fix it and and we've
talked about it quite a bit
um all right thank you my friend
appreciate the call i'm going to move on
a bit
let's talk to andrew from miami
andrew you are on the air hi david can
you hear me yes i can
i'm wondering what your thoughts are on
biden running on
things like canceling student debt or
providing a public option
and then when he actually gains power he
doesn't really seem to have the means or
desire to enact any of those policies
yeah i mean listen i would take issue i
don't know that biden ran
on canceling student debt i think that
towards the end of the campaign
pressure made him say he'd consider
canceling some amount of it
but not fifty thousand dollars i think
he was talking about ten
needless to say as i've said before i
don't think he really has any interest
in doing it
and um on that it's just
he's just not interested in it and i
disagree with him on the policy
but joe biden never seemed to me
interested in
actually doing that now on the public
option
um health care is you know he did covet
stimulus
and that tweaked obamacare to some
degree
and now he's got infrastructure the jobs
plan tax reform
i am still open to the idea that joe
biden will make a good faith effort to
put a public option in place he may not
do it he may not do it
because he doesn't try hard enough or he
may not do it because he's not able to
get it done
i'm reserving judgment until we see
because we're only four months into his
presidency
what does it mean to you to not try hard
enough to get something as significant
as public health option
well listen i mean joe you you sort of
know it when you see it uh joe biden
touts how he's been a deal maker who can
negotiate with democrats and republicans
for his entire career
so if joe biden simply says
i'd like a public option that would be a
great thing and
you know three democrats say we don't
want it and then you never hear about it
again
i think most of us would sort of agree
that's not really trying giving that's
not really giving a good faith effort
if he puts together a proposal with
democrats that want it and it includes a
public option
and when whoever joe manchin or whatever
comes out and says i don't want that
he brings them to the white house and he
meets any lobbies and he pushes
i think we will all know whether it was
a good faith effort or not
well i mean that sort of reminds me of
the discussion that came around the 15
minimum wage um you know he's supposed
to be this great
i mean we don't want to say deal maker
because that reminds us of the previous
administration
yeah but if you're supposed to bring
together democrats and republicans to
to enact things that are overwhelmingly
popular with the public
the 15 minimum wage sort of fell through
and he sort of let that happen by saying
something along the lines of
uh you know we don't think it'll pass
given the current
you know yeah he didn't even i mean
listen he didn't even have every
democratic senator on board it was there
was just no way
and as i've spoken about before we can
argue that
morally the parliamentarian should have
included it
and let them all vote no and in practice
it would have just delayed people
getting a covet cash that's in practice
what it would have done
we would have a naughty and nice list
but we sort of do anyway we sort of know
who is against it
so i i agree with you i don't think
there was any way
anything would happen other than just
delaying people get getting 1400
and i'm for the 15 minimum wage to be
clear
great that's great to hear um it just
seems so interesting how when
things come up in terms of propagating
the war machine
or other things involving funding the
private sector
it always seems like that money is
available but when it comes to funding
and 15 minimum wage
of course and those things are more
difficult to happen for 100
that's we never question where will we
get the money for all these bombs and
missiles and rockets
100 right and and that's an analysis
i've i've been making for some time and
you're you you couldn't be more right
excellent glad you agree thanks so much
david all right gonna let you go the
audio really uh sort of kind of falling
apart there towards the end but it it
sort of held
to some degree for a period of time
let's go
next to uh where do we want to go how
about isaac from wyoming
isaac you're on the air
isaac from wyoming you're on the air
and isaac is gone that's too bad i was
looking forward to speaking to a caller
from
wyoming let's go next to frumpus
from chicago from this year on the air
hang on david hey can you hear me
yes i'm right here okay hi david um
glad to hear you're doing good so i'm
wondering like with the
um with biden not going forward with the
public option
i'm wondering what the strategy is there
because i and a lot of other people
voted
for him um on that and i'm wondering why
he just decided to go with like
lowering these deductibles i think a
public option was even part of
obamacare's uh initial proposal before
it got cut so what's the strategy
i don't know i wish i could tell you and
you know it's not like i'm gonna be
uh uh defending things that i don't
think should be defended i
i don't i don't know the answer to that
and is it part of some bigger strategy
is it part of
i don't know and um we we you know i
think that
being four months in as i said earlier
only four months into the presidency
i'm still sort of open and waiting and
and seeing what the full trajectory is
going to be but i just don't have an
answer
and you know i'm not the defender of
everything biden does that's for sure
yeah i got you i i try to i try to
defend a lot of things biden does but
it's really hard now but like yeah i was
thinking at least rhetorically he could
go with like this was obama's
thing and all this and so it's just
weird okay yeah that's it from me um
my girlfriend loves you by the way love
you all right
thanks guys appreciate it thank you uh
very nice nice phone call
uh okay why don't we go next to bret
from indiana
brett you were on the air hi david can
you hear me yes i can
gosh i have to admit i'm actually super
nervous talking to you right now
you're doing great already i can tell
you're going to be great so
um i'm not gonna lie i'm super
politically active and
i wish i could ask you 20 questions but
i know we're on a limited amount of time
right so i wanted to ask you how you
felt about this so
there's this debate of dc and puerto
rico statehood
yep for me d.c there's no debate
personally i think it needs statehood at
this point
i mean it's for another discussion but
puerto rico to me
is a little bit more complicated because
there's people who think oh
it's just colonizers wanting to just add
it to the united states
and one concern i have about it
is um basically there was a referendum
vote about whether they should
become independent or become a state and
it was 52 to 48 percent
right and i'm just do i'm just concerned
about that number because
my thing is i think that number's way
too low it's not overwhelming
it's not overwhelming and there are
people who say it should have been you
know it should have a 60
threshold or more i mean let's go
through it piece by piece
it is without question that the dc and
puerto rico situations are not the same
there's no question now
you can take the position that both
should be states
probably for slightly different reasons
but there's no question that the dc and
puerto rico situations
are different now one of the differences
is that dc residents are much more
overwhelmingly
in support of being a state than puerto
rican residents are and so what you're
talking about is sort of
the desire of the population and their
ability to to to self-determine
i think that it's morally right to offer
both the opportunity to be states and
certainly
the people that are there can have a say
in that but i agree that they're not the
same situation
right and one more question and then
i'll just hit the road for you so
i was wondering how
do you feel about education in this
country because i've always
argued strongly we should expand upon it
because
i'm in the national guard and the unit i
go to once a month for a drill basically
it's in this small country town in
indiana and
i'm just going to put it plenty of the
high school there it looks like crap
yeah and like i've always argued there's
this
inequality of education funding you know
small country towns they don't get a lot
of
um they don't get a lot of money from
the state
compared to like big city schools and
then you know
schools like you know in places like
i don't want to call it the ghetto
that'd be rude i would call it
rather not very wealthy areas
they don't get as much more than a state
and i was just wondering how do you feel
we should expand upon education in this
country because
trump's presidency certainly made me
realize i feel like we have to work on
education
yeah so i mean at the educational system
this is such a big topic it has
to be completely rethought and reformed
but a couple of things are number one
a lot of this has to do with how states
are run
and you have states that pride
themselves on
we have low or no income tax or we have
very low property taxes or whatever
and then you get schools that are
equivalent
to the amount of of low tax that the
states sort of brag about you have state
boards of education
including for example in texas where
they are just
destroying the curriculum and you you're
not even getting a shot based on what
these boards of education are
are doing so one piece is at the state
level
federal education policy is a really
tough thing and
how do you do federal policy for a
country of 331 million people
it's a really difficult question to
answer and and a very complex one
but part of it is we've had long strings
of incompetent people in federal
education leadership i mean just look at
under trump
betsy devos she had no business being in
that position whatsoever
and so we you know we can talk about
specific reforms
but you've got to completely go back to
the drawing board
with the way that a lot of the where the
funding comes from
how funding is distributed what are the
metrics that are used for evaluating
schools and teachers what is done as a
result of those metrics the system is so
broken as you seem to be pointing out
yes i agree and you know there are
you know i speak um spanish and i'm
learning french and german
and like basically i went to madrid and
i was
really amazed as to how many you know
spanish people they spoke french or then
some of them spoke other languages
because they literally learned
since elementary school basically
languages no well the
the really if you look globally the
surprising thing is how few people in
the united states speak two languages
that's really the surprising thing
globally
but to many americans it's surprising to
see that so many people in other
countries do speak two languages it's
completely backwards brett
it is and yeah and so
i just i just really hope with biden's
presidency something can get done
because
i'll say one thing i am pretty disgusted
with joe manchin and
kirsten cinema too right now because i
feel like they're a work
i feel like they're wolves in sheep's
clothing listen they're they're with us
on a lot of stuff
but they're not with us on enough stuff
that it's a big big concern
brett i appreciate the call thank you
for your service
yeah i appreciate it and by the way fun
fact i just drove past columbus indiana
where mike pence is from
there one they wanted to put up a statue
and then i just saw a sign where they
just said
vice president pence is from here fun
fact
all right brett thank you uh appreciate
that uh that
latest breaking news and hope to hear
from you again uh really close to a
perfect phone call my friends
that is all the time i have for calls
today apologies if i didn't get to you
and i will hope to hear from you on the
next one
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers
and listeners and one way to keep us
going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him all right let's get into
audience questions for the week
a bunch of questions about the recent 60
minutes ufo
uap uh piece that was done
the general gist of the questions is
david what's your view
about the truth of the recent ufo uap
story now uap is a relatively at least
in the public space new term for
uh unidentified foreign objects called
unidentified aerial phenomena sorry
unidentified flying objects
the new uap is unidentified aerial
phenomena
um my view on this is
i don't think anybody is
lying about what they believe they saw
when you see
a pilot interviewed and saying we saw
this moving in that way at this speed
and we don't know this that the other
thing
i believe everybody so far is being
honest in their perceptions
i believe we only have part of the story
and i have no evidence at this point
that we are dealing with aliens from
another planet and this is the most
important thing to remember just because
we say
there's a ufo that's an unidentified
flying object it's an object that's
flying and we don't know exactly what it
is
uh doesn't mean that it's aliens and
similarly an unidentified aerial
phenomena
has the sort of same analysis now i've
said before
if there is an intelligent interstellar
um traveling uh species or
huma or society of some kind that comes
to the united states
if we default to treating it as a threat
the way for example marco rubio said
these uaps ufos are def
these are threats uh well it may be a
threat if they are
you know if it's spy technology from an
adversary
then we're talking about national
security but if we did
get a visit from aliens uh and we treat
it as a threat when they are actually
not a threat
if they come in peace so to speak um
then we could potentially
uh destroy what would be a historic
species-changing encounter
and the reality is that at this point
since we lack the technology to do
what we imagine maybe someday would
happen which is some
uh alien race from somewhere else in the
universe comes to the united states if
they came with nefarious goals
it's abundantly clear that at least at
this time
we would be able to do nothing to
prevent them from either killing all of
us or enslaving all of us or whatever so
for me
the national security analysis makes
more sense if we're conceding that the
most likely explanation
is that this is either something from a
foreign power
in which case by the way if we really
don't understand what it is
then they are way further ahead than us
in many ways and we should be extremely
worried
or it's also possible that
these are unidentified or unknown
to the pilots and people that were
interviewed for the 60 minutes piece
but that it actually is classified at a
level above their
uh pay grade or level of access and the
people who know what these things are
did not participate uh because maybe 60
minutes doesn't even know who they are
so i i think my main point here is
for me the most serious approach to this
ufo uap
thing is first of all there is no
evidence that this is aliens from
somewhere other than earth there's just
no evidence of that
and it's fascinating to think of and i
understand
the equations about the probability of
intelligent life other than just on
earth
earth and i recognize that if we were
ever to make that first contact it would
truly be an incredible thing
i'm not saying it's not possible i'm
just saying there's no evidence that
this is
that then it gets to the question of
assuming that it is indeed
man-made technology then
what is the source of it is it something
american that is so classified that even
the people interviewed don't know what
it is
uh or is it something foreign and then
you get the people who say well the
physics of it doesn't make sense
there were uh dissents in altitude
that would have killed any human body
that was in there
okay maybe there wasn't a human body in
there we also know
that the way a lot of these things are
filmed and perspective and lenses can
make something seem different than what
it might look like to the naked eye
the where i come back to is
sort of an occam's razor type question
which is which of these explanations
require the fewest assumptions and the
ones that require the fewest assumptions
are
the visual perception that the pilots
claim is not entirely accurate that
would be a very straightforward way to
explain away a lot of this or
this is stuff that is known it's not
unidentified it was unidentified to the
pilots
and maybe to air traffic control but
it's
technology that higher up we are aware
of
or it was human-made technology from
some other pla like the
from some other country the one that is
the furthest and requires the most
assumptions of course
would be the alien one which is there is
an alien species
that is advanced enough to travel to
earth
from really far in the universe because
we've been observing the universe that's
more immediately around us for a very
long time
and to do it without uh any other
signature be it radio waves or whatever
else and right so the number of
assumptions start to go up
significantly so that's not where i am
on this now just one other thought on
this
one thing i read was the information
that was released
was fake information released by the us
government
to trick other countries what's the idea
here this is quite cynical
and if you go down this rabbit hole
the pilots interviewed on 60 minutes
could be in on it or not they might not
even be in on it the idea would be
let's make some video and have pilots
tell stories or otherwise convince
pilots of the reality of this
so that 60 minutes we'll do a piece
we'll have some big reveal about these
uap ufos
and this will be seen by our adversaries
and it will completely misdirect them
so that they will start sinking r d
money into what they think they need to
do to develop
these things and it's just it's either
digital
it's not even real it's just been made
uh on a computer
um and it's a way to get adversaries to
spend money unfortunately
that's not totally implausible compared
to the alien theory
uh the the deliberate misdirection
campaign
by by the us government strikes me as
more plausible
send me your thoughts that's kind of
where my head is on this at this point
in time
hey david how could republicans convince
young people to start voting for them
yeah so there's still this really big
imbalance
um in the 2020 us election presidential
60 percent of voters 18 to 29 voted for
joe biden
60 only 36 percent voted for donald
trump
i think a lot of this is sort of a
culture war
issue related and i'll explain it to you
in this way
um the republican party historically has
had
their sort of more religious and and
cultural issues
and then their policy platforms the
policy platform of low taxes and low
regulation
it's not really appealing to young
people and
that is not a draw for young people to
the republican party
when the country was more religious
stuff like being against gay marriage
and being against abortion maybe did
more to pull some young people
in to the republican party but over time
we are seeing that even so-called
conservative young people tend to have
significantly more liberal views when it
comes to economic issues than they did
15 or 20 years ago the occupy wall
street movement was a part of that and
other things have affected that
they are increasingly less religious so
like gay marriage
abortion are not big issues for most
young people
so what does the republican have to
offer them um
maybe the new culture war issues could
potentially work so
for example if somebody like madison
cawthorne a
young republican elected official from
north carolina not south carolina as i
misstated last week
if madison cawthorne can get young
people really fixated on the new
cultural issues which include
you know de-platforming and free speech
and
censorship cancel culture
and that type of thing maybe that's a
way that the republican party could
capture more of the young vote
that's a possibility the problem as i
see it
is that the republican party on policy
doesn't really have much right now other
than
oppose democrats cut welfare programs
and cut taxes they are against the
affordable care act but they don't
really have a solution
and young people are probably aware that
if aca goes
if i'm under 26 i may not be able to
stay on my parents insurance so
there's no interesting policy ideas and
so as interesting as the idea of we're
going to fight cancel culture and we're
going to fight against
policing of speech and de-platforming
and all this stuff
that might be interesting to some young
people and might pull them towards the
republican party
if they care at all about policy there's
going to be nothing there so
i think that unless there's a wholesale
change within the republican party
they're going to keep hemorrhaging young
voters now that being said
still given how ridiculous republican
policy has been towards anything that
young people would care about
it's shocking they still got 36 trump
trump still got 36
of the 18 to 29 vote doing everything
wrong they still got 36 percent of the
vote so this is one of those things
where
on the one hand the republican party is
doing everything wrong to try to appeal
to young people and the things
i think could help them appeal to more
young people are not things they seem
interested in doing so that seems
terrible it spells disaster
but yet on the other hand they still got
36
of the 18 to 29 votes so only some small
tweaks could
probably make them quite competitive or
at least closer to competitive
among that group give me your sense
of whether there's a way to maintain
something that is the modern republican
ideology
that would appeal to young people i'm
not really sure that there is
hey david what happened to defund the
police
did they do it and why isn't anyone
talking about it anymore
yeah i don't know if the question is
being asked cynically or sarcastically
or rhetorically
so a bunch of different things happen
first of all
society has just sort of moved on in
some sense
and i don't mean all together from
defund the police there's still a
ton of activism going on but it's not
the lead story
on cnn msnbc and fox every single day
it's not making headlines in the world's
most read the
country's most read newspapers so in a
sense it the topic of defund the police
has simmered down now you all know
i was never for defund the police i was
for
how would i say it i was for fund more
crime prevention and better train police
by providing
the appropriate resources for the
policing situation
as judged on an individual basis that's
a terrible tagline
i'm not a marketing guy i admit that um
but
for me the idea of
eliminating or defunding police never
made sense i laid out all the reasons
why
it and and absent some real way to
prevent crime
um defunding police i just don't think
is something that that was ever going to
really catch on now what i do think
is typically police are responding to
crime so sure
investigative new units joint terrorism
task force
fbi cia dea you know you've all these
different entities and many of them are
working on
preventing major crimes from happening
in advance police mostly are responding
to crimes and are not
nearly as often in a situation where
they can prevent one sometimes
police interfere in or interject into a
situation
where a crime has been committed and
they prevent further crime so in a
shooting where two people have been
killed police show up
maybe nobody else gets killed which
could happen if the shooter is just left
alone but for the most part police are
not really
day-to-day street police are not
preventing
crime in the way that maybe we would
like to see happen
um access to social workers and mental
health services
prevents crime food stamps and anything
that makes people
uh enough to be in a less desperate
situation where there might they might
feel
uh compelled to commit a crime to feed
their family or themselves
that prevents crime good schools prevent
prime
prevent crime good public transit so
people can get to where
the jobs are that prevents crime
affordable sports and you know the way
that we prevent crime
has less to do with police themselves
with all of the exceptions that i listed
so i think that the focus
should really be let's fund
crime prevention and reform the police
with the 10 to 12 bullet point outline
that i've given
in the past um in terms of just the
the dialogue around defund there are
cities that recently have been seeing
more violence
not because they defunded now this is
really important you see
some republicans don jr will do this
he'll say look at what defund the police
brought to this city and then you look
and it's like yeah
they had to defund the police protest
but the police weren't defunded
you can't blame defunding the police for
crime when the police were not defunded
i do think that more visible crime in
some cities over the last six months
has probably a little bit taken the wind
out of the sales
of the straight-up defund movement it
should do nothing at all
to take our minds off of the fund crime
prevention
and reform the police movement that's
where i've been for years on this
issue and i see more of my audience
coming around to it
and i think that that's a very good
thing let me know what you think
and we have a fantastic bonus show
planned for you today
join pacman.com and sign up to get
instant access to today's bonus show we
will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman